parmi les spectacles donnés en ce début
d'année l'un d'entre eux a été
particulièrement remarqué il a été mis
en scène par Alfredo Arias il est joué
en ce moment à bobini avant de partir en
tournée il s'appelle peine de cœur d'une
chatte française reportage Xavier
Colombier 15 minutes 15 minutes et là je
parle je parle mais en fait faut
chauffer la voix
ah ça va Brisquet le matou séducteur
retrouve minette la pauvre petite chatte
française au peine de cœur les
illustrations de Grandville prennent
visage en fait la la
mâchoire elle était faite sur notre
moulage donc elle tient vraiment
parfaitement et c'est vrai que ça finit
bien le le masque illustré en 1840 par
Grandville ses peines de cœur avaient
été oublié Alfredo Arias l'enchanteur a
donc mis du temps pour remettre la main
sur le deuxième volet de ce
bestiaire une étoile
pour
[Musique]
vité un spectacle fantastique c'est un
spectacle qui parle des rêves
métamorphoses aussi qui regardent les
hommes d'une façon
fantastique rarement théâtre musical
aura eu visage plus tendre plus humain
il ne volent pas
trè